different parts of the world are
exploring other things like sesame
credit in China or genetic engineering
without regulations so people are kind
of tweaking around with things you know
Ron was saying Matt was pointing at this
earlier just this idea of maybe it's
maybe it is totally fine you know we are
talking about prioritizing humanity over
the markets and putting ubi in early and
saving people's lives and like yeah
their likelihood livelihoods and then
this alternatives like well what happens
we're like aren't we fighting against
evolution the survival of the fittest
right now there are these groups of
people on the planet that have
accumulated so much wealth they have
they have made so much impact and the
other ones might not have and it's a
roll of the dice for you to be born in
the place that has a that is just less
socioeconomic status than another and so
is it is it our responsibility is it the
responsibility of high assess to figure
out how to funnel money through things
like this value out of tax and universal
basic income and figure that out
or should they just specie eight and go
like I'll be in the poor class and I
just won't be able to keep up right and
just like go specie eight go call an
Isis cosmos and maybe your kids and
their kids and whatnot maybe will like
just like leave it behind
well I mean I know you know people that
have that point of view and to me the
whole thing is just so dumb because like
let's say I'm you know a rich person in
San Francisco do I really think that you
know the society can disintegrate and
that like my life will be just as like
easy and happy and frictionless as it is
now like of course not
like if I have to hire bodyguards and
get a bulletproof car and like you know
take my kids out of school and get like
a bunker somewhere and like you know I
have to redecorate the bunker that's you
know and like have to live with my
constant anxiety and fear because
studies have shown that people who are
at the top of unequal societies are less
happy than people who are at the top of
more equal societies so to me it's just
like enlightened self-interest
be like look let's try and keep society
whole and it's not like the the like the
survival of the fittest thing I mean
like you know it's like it's not like
people stop having kids by the numbers I
mean right now is we're sitting here 40%
of American children are born to a
single or none married mother so bad and
it's it's not good and so but it just
goes to show that it's not like all of a
sudden is like a total curtailment of
like reproduction I mean that's not the
case you know so but but there is
something very fundamental there which
is like if you follow just like the
economic rationale being like I'm more
than a billion like you're worth zero
then you wind up in very very dark
dystopian realities very very quickly